alala ce petit son fort agréable des
gens qui sont en train de tondre dans le
jardin salue aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de votre crédibilité lorsque vous
parler avec quelqu'un si vous avez subi
la chaîne du battlelog vous savez que le
non verbal est un élément essentiel
d'une conversation peut-être d'ailleurs
que vous vous amusez à décrypter celui
des autres mais est-ce que vous êtes
déjà posé la question sur votre propre
crédibilité lorsque vous parlez essayer
de comprendre l'autre c'est très bien
mais prendre soin des propres signaux
qu'on l'envoie soi même c'est encore
mieux et c'est un respect du non verbal
qu'on n'a jamais abordé sur cette chaîne
entre nous entre menthe à l'eau voici
donc cinq choses à connaître sur le non
verbal sur le vote ont certaines études
liens dans la description ont prouvé que
plus une personne montré des signes de
nervosité de stress d'un confort - elle
était crédible cela signifie pas
forcément qu'elle ment on parle bien ici
de la perception naturel que ce fait
l'autre interlocuteur donc dans le cadre
d'un entretien d'embauché d'une
conversation professionnelle d'une
conversation personnelle on peut passer
malgré soi pour quelqu'un de pas
forcément bien fiable juste à cause du
stress
faites attention à votre discours chose
que vous dites parce que les hésitations
sur des questions simples et franches
sont très mal perçue par la personne
d'en face si on vous demande quelles
sont vos diplômes ou ce que vous avez
fait succinctement ce week end et que
vous hésitez tous les deux mots bah
c'est pas bon signe
de même si vous utilisez trop si vous
abusez des intensifs hier ils auront
l'effet inverse que vous vouliez au
départ les intensifs hier ne s'est pas
les intensifier j'aime vraiment beaucoup
ce cadeau il est incroyablement bien
c'est furieusement tellement ce que je
voulais c'est trop dans mes vidéos sur
le mensonge vous parlais aussi des
gestes tranquillisants je vous mets les
liens de ces vidéos dans la description
également vous avez conseillé d'être
prudent sur les conclusions à en tirer
en général ce sont de bons indicateurs
de l'état de nervosité ou l'état
d'excitation contenu d'une personne pas
nécessairement de son honnêteté ou pas
sauf qu'ici dans notre conversation
d'aujourd'hui c'est vous qu'on décrypte
consciemment ou inconsciemment et la
personne d'en face aura le sentiment
qu'avec beaucoup de gestes parasites de
votre part essentiellement sur le visage
on se touche un petit peu là ici comme
ça elle aura l'impression que vous
n'êtes pas réellement sincère elle aura
tort c'est sûr mais ce sera déjà trop
tard je ne peux pas faire cette vidéo
sans parler de la légende urbaine des
bras croisés c'est une légende urbaine
s'il ya bien un truc que tout le monde
est persuadé de connaître sur le langage
non verbal qui se soit réellement
intéressés ou pas ou même
d'une seconde dans la vie ce sont les
bras croisés tout le monde a une théorie
la personne est en train de faire une
barrière elle refuse le discours etc etc
alors c'est pas faux mais c'est pas vrai
non plus pour être précis c'est pas
suffisant pour faire une conclusion
franchement faire une conclusion précise
il faut avoir le reste qu'on appelle la
base line mais encore une fois c'est pas
parce que vous vous le savez que la
personne en face
elle est au courant aussi elle va
forcément l'interpréter malgré elle donc
éviter de le faire
cinquième point je me suis rendu compte
que je l'ait déjà abordé c'était sur les
intensifs hier j'en ai déjà parlé dans
le point numéro deux avec les
hésitations donc vous aviez un double
point sans le savoir et sans que je le
sache
c'est énorme en prenant conscience de
tout ça et en faisant attention
maintenant quand vous parlez à quelqu'un
vous allez pas être moins sincères vous
serez toujours le même et vous serez
toujours authentiques mais en maîtrisant
tous vos signaux votre discours sera
mieux entendu vous serez donc mieux
perçu donc plus crédible donc plus
entendre merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
pensez également à vous abonner
si c'est pas encore le cas puisque ici
depuis 90 jours là juste là sur cette
chaîne du mental blog il ya une vidéo
par jour
alors rendez vous demain à 17 heures
ciao
et